Sometimes things happen during post-production
that result in a complete film never being
released.
Studios lose a few million, actors lose a
hard-earned credit on their résumé, and
the world is deprived of a potential cinematic
masterpiece.
Here are some films that are out there, somewhere,
but have never been officially unleashed.
The Fantastic Four
Before a cinematic universe was even a gleam
in Marvel's eye, the company raised money
by selling off the film rights to its characters,
including the Fantastic Four.
German production company Constantin Film
paid $250,000 for the FF rights in 1983—and
sat on them until 1992.
Faced with the agreement's expiration and
needing to actually film something to retain
their rights, they slapped together a low-budget
movie in under a month.
Fantastic Four never hit theaters, as Marvel
bought back the rights for a few million and
demanded every copy's destruction.
One leaked, however, and quickly became one
of the more legendary bootlegs appearing at
comic conventions.
Big Bug Man
Big Bug Man is the last movie Marlon Brando
ever made, and it’s never been seen.
In this adult animated superhero comedy, Brando
plays the villain, "Mrs. Sour," an evil old
lady.
All of Brando's lines were recorded in his
home, where the ailing thespian insisted on
being dressed as an actual old lady, including
makeup.
It sounds pretty nutty, but we still hope
to see this one some day.
Especially since Brando told the crew that
it was the most fun he'd had making a movie
since 1953's Julius Caesar.
Dark Blood
River Phoenix plays a man named Boy who lives
in the middle of a desert and becomes fixated
on a married woman.
There's a kidnapping, an axe fight with a
jealous husband, and a whole lot of shots
of the desert.
Phoenix died in 1993 with a few scenes left
unfilmed, although director George Sluizer
cobbled together a final cut almost 20 years
later.
It’s never been seen outside of a few film
festivals.
Gods Behaving Badly
Based on a comic novel about gods living in
modern day New York City, Gods Behaving Badly
features an all-star cast that includes Phylicia
Rashad as Demeter and John Turturro as Hades.
Some of the only things that have surfaced
from this film are a bit of the title sequence
and some pictures of the cast, notably Christopher
Walken, standing next to Turturro, wearing
a ridiculous curly wig and a gold headband.
It's hard to find a reason why this film never
made it past one film festival in Italy, but
The Hollywood Reporter compared it to a “bad
1990s SNL sketch.”
Ouch.
The Day the Clown Cried
“Holocaust drama” isn’t the first thing
that comes to mind when you think of Jerry
Lewis, but that’s the premise of The Day
the Clown Cried, directed by and starring
the slapstick comedian.
Lewis plays a washed-up German circus clown
named Helmut Dork who’s forced by the Nazis
to trick children into the gas chamber.
Lewis has repeatedly vowed that the film will
never be released.
He claims that it’s because the rights to
the screenplay were never properly secured.
But those who have seen it claim it’s because
it’s a disaster.
Harry Shearer, best known for his voice work
on The Simpsons, is one of the few who’s
seen it.
He’s called the film "drastically wrong"
and remarked that it's even worse than anyone
could imagine.
“If you say Jerry Lewis clown in a concentration
camp and you make that movie up in your head,
right, it’s so much better than that, by
better I mean worse.
If you happen to actually see it, there's
really only one appropriate response.
“What the hell was that”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
of these lost movies you’d most like to
see...